[Music]
hey you guys back once again thought I'd
just jump on here and do a movie review
like I said I was going to on Friday
night uh before we get started let me
just do a quick thing about our
affiliate for this video which is going
to be skillshare uh most people know
what skillshare is it's a subscription
service which a bunch of uh with a bunch
of online classes usually things having
to do with creativity so it's anything
to do with graphic design video editing
painting figure drawing anything like
that productivity is like classes like
that and they have all kind of classes
for every single uh level that you may
be at from beginner to to expert and
there's just thousands of them and you
can pick whatever you want on there and
if you click the link that's down in the
description box you will get a free thir
30-day monthlong you know what I mean
30-day uh trial of skillshare where you
can take all of the classes that you
want to it's a pretty great deal uh so
yeah uh full disclosure obviously if you
click on that link and subscribe to
skillshare I get a small commission but
yeah it's a great deal you'll be able to
access all of the classes for free for
30 days so check it out by clicking on
the link in the description box so now
let's get into this movie now I'm you
know a 70s and 80s girl obviously and so
I'm pretty much always game to check out
like an 80s horror movie that I somehow
missed the first time around so in one
of you guys um I can't remember exactly
who it was but I think it was in one of
the YouTube comments one of y'all
recommend commended uh the 1981 movie
fear no evil and I looked for it and I H
and I noticed that it happened to be on
shutter so I decided I was going to go
over there and give it a look now I seem
to remember seeing the cover of this hi
Kenny how are you doing um back like in
the video store back in the day but for
whatever reason I don't think I ever
rented it like when I watched it nothing
about it was familiar um sometimes it
happens that I'm like oh I never saw
this movie back in the but then when I
watch it I'm just like oh yeah maybe I
did see it this one did not seem
familiar to me at all cuz I'm pretty
sure I would have remembered um so I
don't know why I didn't rent it back in
the 80s cuz I rented pretty much
everything else um maybe it just didn't
stand out all that much or whatever it
just got overlooked somehow so I had
actually never really seen this one now
although I didn't know this until after
I watched it and was like researching it
fear no evil was actually the
directorial debut of Frank loia he wrote
this movie movie too now he would
actually go on to direct one of my
favorite 80s ghost stories and a movie
that I always recommend for parents that
have you know kind of younger kids that
are trying that are trying to like get
them into horror um he directed The Lady
in White from 1988 which is a great
movie if you haven't seen it I think I
reviewed it last year maybe around
Halloween or the year before I can't
remember but I have like reviewed it I
really really like that movie I saw it a
bunch of times back in the ' 80s so this
is the same director now I will say that
that had I not found that out I wouldn't
have I wouldn't have ever figured that
out on my own because fear no evil is
like entirely different and I'm going to
say it's like a lot
cheesier than the lady in white was um
but I mean fear no evil does have a few
good things going for it the best thing
of which is the soundtrack the
soundtrack for this movie totally slaps
I was really really into it um it has
songs by The Sex Pistols it has boom
toown rats Talking Heads The Ramones
b52s um the rosillos Patty Smith and
Richard hell like all in one soundtrack
I was just like you know these songs
were play in the background like holy
[__] like another really good one it was
like it was amazing um so yeah so I love
that about it that was probably my
favorite thing about it now the story
does take some cues from The
Omen and from Carrie for sure cuz it's
kind of a relig just horror but like
kind of filtered through like a high
school kind of lens there's kind of two
things going on at one time which I'll
get into in a little bit um and I'm
going to say it even has like a slight
grease influence which might sound kind
of bizarre but I'll kind of get into
that too um but yeah so like I said it
leans pretty hard into the religious
horror angle um so much so like it's
very Catholic so it almost gave me a
slight like Alice Sweet Alice Vibe at
times too cuz the because of all the
Catholic imagery and stuff stuff but
yeah so this is a religious horror movie
but also has like a bunch of Post Punk
and like high school stuff going on
which so it's kind of weird like tonally
it's kind of weird and I'm going to say
overall I didn't love it I didn't love
it um the pacing was kind of uneven um
you know some of the parts of mie were R
slow and some of the acting was a little
bit cringe um and kind of overwrought I
thought and I'm not sure if there wasn't
some maybe unintentional homophobia
going on in there um I'm not entirely
sure like what the intent was um but
we'll get into that in a little bit um
now I mean the movie overall it does
have some really weird like kind of what
the [__] moments that are definitely
entertaining because you're just like
okay so we're doing that now but I'm not
sure if there were like enough of them
to make up for these kind of like long
stretches of the movie where it was just
kind of slow and sort of boring you know
what I mean so the movie starts out it's
sometime in the past I'm not entirely
sure like what year it's supposed to be
but we have like a Roman Catholic priest
whose name is Father Damon and he is
supposedly the temporary human form of
the Archangel Raphael right so there's
this kind of battle between good and
evil um which takes place at this kind
of castle looking place it's a real
building that they shot it at in Upstate
New York like it's on this island and it
kind of looks like a castle I don't know
who built it I don't know what the story
is behind it but yeah I've seen it in
other movies though now the inside of
the castle like it's decorated with like
lots of sacrific animals hanging
everywhere and then there's like a dead
lady in there too like now I'm going to
say too that there's a lot of dead
animals in this and they all look like
real dead animals so you know what I
mean I'm just saying like dead dogs and
whatnot so if that's going to bother cuz
it kind of bothered me not going to lie
um you know I I know that there's places
where you can go to get fresh dead
animals for movies and stuff which is
kind of messed up and I'm sure that's
where they got them I'm not saying they
killed the animals for the movie or
nothing like that but it's just kind of
like I don't know it it just kind I was
kind of like uncomfortable about it so
yeah so so this whole good versus evil
battle takes place now Damon father
Damon ends up killing a man who claims
to be
Lucifer he's
got they do like some Demon makeup on
him like with these big teeth and like
these contact lenses but the funniest
thing about it is his hair because his
hair kind of reminded me of um do you
remember that stuff where where they
like for a time I don't know if they
still make this or not but where they
used to like sell jars where it was
peanut butter and jelly like in the same
jar and they were like Stripes okay well
his hair is kind of like that except not
peanut butter and jelly colored
obviously but it was just kind of like
he had like so he had like these white
stripes in his hair and then like the
rest of the hair was like regular
colored and I was just kind of like well
that was a choice okay so Lucifer has
hair like that you know what I mean he's
only in it for like two minutes or
something but I just thought the hair
was like really funny so father Damon
kills this guy who claims to be Lucifer
by impaling him through the chest like
against this big tree like with this big
like staff style cross thing that he's
got like you know it's like it's like a
staff but with a cross on it you see
like Catholic priest carry him and [__]
like that now Lucifer doesn't seem all
that upset about getting killed I mean
cuz he basically tells I'll be reborn
anyway you know no Brimstone off my
Hooves or whatever now we find out later
on that the authorities obviously did
not believe that this murdered man was
actually Lucifer in human form so they
ended up sending father Damon to prison
where he subsequently died although I
will say that there are scenes of him in
prison that I thought were supposed to
be taking place in the present day but I
guess not because then they say that
he's dead so I'm like oh well that must
have been a flashback but they didn't
make it like super clear or I wasn't
paying enough attention I'm not really
sure but so I was like wait I thought he
was dead like why are we having a scene
with him but whatever it doesn't matter
so the story then jumps ahead to I think
it's
1963 and we see the birth of this baby
boy named Andrew to a couple named Mr
Mrs
Williams now they take the baby to be
christened and at the christening
there's all kind of like Supernatural
jiggery pokery going on um like this
mysterious wind like blows through the
church and like snatches stuff out of
the priest's hand and all that other
kind of stuff and then there's like
blood coming out of the religious
statues and also kind of spewing out
from underneath the baby's sleeves which
okay I mean seems like a big red flag
but yeah there you go everyone's like
holy [__] and like runs out of the
[__] church or whatever so then we
jump ahead another 18 years now I kind
of like the way they did the transition
here instead of just going well I mean I
think it does say 18 years later but
what they did was we only see like the
outside of the williams' house and then
like it begins to slowly deteriorate
with the implication being that it's
like they have all of these problems and
they can't keep their [__] together like
they can't keep their house together and
like shit's going wrong you know what I
mean and we just hear voiceovers of Mr
and Mrs Williams like having a series of
arguments about their son Andrew and
like maybe there's something wrong with
him and like he's probably driving a
wedge between them and like taking away
any love that they felt for each other
and blahy blah so I kind of I liked that
transition I thought that was really
like effectively done like cuz it said a
lot without you know with just showing a
little bit like imp implied a lot you
know what I mean which I thought was
really good like really efficient uh hi
there Leslie uh hello jenet cool movie
yeah it's you know I didn't love it but
it was it was pretty good it was pretty
good um okay so it turns out this is
Andrew's 18th birthday so Mom has made
him a cake and then she puts it on the
table and dad goes upstairs to get the
kid well I mean he's not a kid he's 18
but you know what I mean um but we only
see Andrew Shadow for a little while and
then when Dad goes downstairs like the
creepy 18-year-old is already sitting at
the kitchen table even though nobody saw
him come into the room you know what I
mean so there's like implying that he's
obviously like Supernatural you know now
Andrew incidentally is played by um
Stefan I guess it's Stefan Aram um I
actually recognized him from a couple of
other movies uh class of 1984 he was in
that and Strange Days from 1995 he was
in that as well I think it was a pretty
small part but I remembered him from
that but uh fans of classic TV will also
know that he is the older brother I
believe of Allison arram um who
obviously played Nelly Olsen on Little
House on the Prairie now when I was
doing research for this movie I also
found out alarmingly that Alison arram
later claimed that her brother Stefan
had molested her all throughout her
childhood and it's also been rumored too
that Stefan himself was molested as a
child like by I think cuz they were both
child stars I think so like they had
like a press agent and like a
photographer so I think it was like two
different people that molested him like
allegedly so yeah so that's not great
but I will say that whether whatever the
case like whether any of that is true or
not um the creepiness that he puts
across in this like the fact that he's
like so creepy actually makes him really
effective in this movie um and I will
say that other than the soundtrack which
was my favorite thing but I think his
performance well I don't want to go that
far cuz like there were some parts where
I was just kind of like okay like he
made like some bizarre choices but the
fact that he's like so creepy and
awkward and kind of a off putting like
kind of made him like really effective
in this role is what I'm going to say
cuz he's essentially playing Lucifer
obviously now while they're having this
birthday party the 18th birthday party
um Dad kind of fumbles like an idiot and
drops the cake on the floor when he's
trying to light the candles now Mom was
probably an overreaction but she starts
like smacking him cuz he's cuz he's
clumsy and he messed the cake up and
then Dad you know big escalation kind of
like hauls off and knocks mom like onto
the floor and then it turns out that
there's like an iron that was on a table
and it falls off and like beans her in
the head and like knocks her out cold
now at first I thought she was dead but
it turns out she survived but I guess
she had like really severe brain damage
cuz when they show her next she's like
she can't really talk and she can't
really move and stuff like that hey
everybody what's going
on yeah Danny rollington yeah yeah
that's what so like I didn't even
realize that the connection between
until I looked up the guy that was in
this movie and I was just like oh he's
Nelly Olsen's older brother and also
allegedly she said that he molested her
so I'm like oh well that's not great
yeah so because Andrew this 18-year-old
is so uh creepy he's unsurprisingly uh
bullied a lot at high school now he's
like one of those he's super intelligent
obviously because he's Lucifer um so he
gets straight A's and I thought this was
kind of funny like later on he gets
accepted to Harvard Yale and Colombia
and he gets like full scholarships and
everything so I was just kind of like
man they're really piling it on you but
he's Lucifer like I said he knows
everything so yeah now one of his main
tormentors I guess sort of is this dude
named Tony now Tony reminded me a lot of
a cross between Billy Nolan from Carrie
either the book or you know John
Travolta played him in the movie um and
Buddy repperton from Christine if you
guys remember that because it's like
it's the same kind of thing he has like
those it's you know it's 1980 1981 so
they had those terrible like tight like
whsh jeans and um he had like that black
like feathered hair you know what I mean
and [__] [__] like that and he's um
you know he smokes weed he's like talks
back to all the teachers he clearly
looks like he's about like 29 years old
but you know what I mean maybe he was
held back a few times I don't know um oh
and also he smacks around his girlfriend
Marie which again not great uh Marie as
it so happens has this satin jacket it's
like purple and gold or something like
that and it says queen bee like
embroidered on the back and then all her
friends have matching jackets that just
say the bees on them so I'm guessing
this is kind of like the dollar store
Pink Ladies that's where kind of like
the grease similarities like came in
because you could tell that they were
trying to make them like the Pink Ladies
although they don't really do a lot with
that you know what I mean it's but it's
the same kind of thing that they're
trying to get across I guess so anyway
not too long after this like the whole
High School thing is established there's
a really weird scene after gym class
where like all the students all the male
students like they're all naked and they
all go in the shower like the communal
shower whatever like they used to have
in gym class I don't know if they have
that anymore um it's been a long time
since I've been in high school and this
was even longer ago than than I was at
high school now while they're all in the
shower like Tony starts harassing Andrew
like asking him for a date right and
then he goes over Andrew is just like
ignoring him like what the [__] ever you
know what I mean but then he goes over
and like kisses Andrew like pretty
passionately I will say like kind of
like pushing him into the corner like
like full-on like [__] sexual it's
all right but then like while that's
going on it's almost kind of like
Andrew I don't know it's it's really
weird like the way that like I said I'm
not really sure what the intention was
here like Tony starts to freak out
because Andrew is supposedly doing
something to him like while they're
kissing but I'm not entirely clear what
that is cuz I thought something was
going to happen like cuz it looked like
he was kind of like going to bite his
tongue off or something I'm like holy
[__] is he going to bite his tongue off
but that doesn't happen but that's what
I thought was going to happen you know
what I mean or like I don't know lasers
were going to shoot out of his mouth or
something like that I thought something
was going to happen but nothing does but
then Tony is just like oh he did
something but he wouldn't like say what
it was I was like maybe they needed a
special effect there or something like
that so it was clearer like what was
happening but I don't know it it doesn't
matter now like Andrew after it happens
and like all the other dudes are just
like whoa we're out of here that was
some weird [__] action or whatever
but Andrew just kind of
seems kind of upset and like bewildered
by the whole thing like he's just kind
of sitting in the um corner of the
shower like kind of freaking out like
what the [__] just happened you know
what I mean um it kind of becomes plain
as the story story goes on that even
though um you know the kid is obviously
Lucifer like reincarnated I don't think
that he's fully aware of his identity or
like in control of his satanic Powers I
think that like when he's upset the [__]
just like takes over and then because he
seems to feel bad about it afterwards so
I guess he's still like fighting with
you know what I mean which I think they
kind of did in the omen sequels too if I
remember correctly although it's been a
while since I've seen them so while all
this high school stuff is going on um
there's also kind of a I don't know if I
call it a b plot because I guess it's
like they're like two plots that
eventually converge right so there's
this older neighbor lady whose name is
Margaret now in reality much like Father
Damon from the beginning of the movie
she is also the you know the human form
of an archangel uh in her case they keep
calling her male instead of Archangel
Michael but whatever so I'm guessing
that's who she's supposed to be I think
that she's also at least in her human
form is the sister of the of Father
Damon like the dead priest that died in
prison now I think okay so what is going
on here is that there are supposed to be
three
archangels who've been sent to Earth to
fight Lucifer's new embodiment or
whatever right but Raphael at least his
human body already got killed in jail
and the third Archangel who they call
Gabriel
which I'm assuming is Gabriel um has
apparently like yet to manifest in human
form right um so okay so this wasn't all
that clear from the movie I have to say
but it turns out that much like Andrew
is maybe Lucifer but doesn't know it yet
I guess that you can also be housing an
archangel and not know until the time
comes to kind of like battle evil or
whatever but Margaret knows who she is
though but she's kind of getting
discouraged because because the third
Archangel Gabrielle hasn't contacted her
yet and she's like I know that it's
getting you know time to like kick some
luciferian ass or whatever and it's like
where is the other Archangel like they
should have been here by now you know
what I mean so it's that kind of
situation now meanwhile back in the High
School portion of the movie Andrew has
kind of has a crush on they don't go way
in this direction but she kind of has a
crush on this classmate named Julie but
she's already engaged to another dude
named Mark
now one day during gym class again I I
don't know if like the the writer of the
movie had like some Aaj of bad [__]
happened to him in gym class I mean you
know I guess we all did but yeah so
they're in gym and Andrew like he kind
of showed up late so while the you know
and the and the um gym teacher is like
the kind of stereotypical hard ass like
get down and give me 20 you know what I
mean that kind of D so he shows up a
little bit late so while the other dudes
are doing whatever um he makes Andrew
kind kind of like do push-ups or sit-ups
or whatever so while so all the other
dudes are playing dodgeball which I
thought was like super funny so they
divide like into two teams and they're
put just chucking balls at each other
and I guess Andrew sort of like loses it
while the other guys are playing
dodgeball and he's over there doing
push-ups and he
supernaturally like causes one of the
balls to slam into Mark so hard that it
kind of like throws him up against the B
features which are all kind of like
folded up against the wall and it kind
of like looks like it ruptures all his
organs I guess is what happens it kind
of reminded me of um of um deadly friend
that West Craven movie where the where
um the robot girl like throws the
basketball at that woman's head and the
head head explodes it's not quite that
splashy or memorable but it was kind of
similar kind of thing going on so again
this like so he kills Mark but again
this seems unintentional because he
seems really distraught about it
afterward like he didn't mean to do it
but he just got so mad that you know the
ball just flew out because he didn't
throw the ball I think the coach
actually threw it but he threw it really
hard now I will note that he's
distraught but not so distraught that he
doesn't kind of paranormally turn up in
Julie's bed to kind of like molest her a
little bit and also kind of like leaves
the three demonic scratches like on her
shoulder you know what I mean and he
kind of like floats outside her window a
little bit like the git kid in uh
Salem's Lot so I'm not really sure if
that's what they were homaging but it
kind of reminded me of that so like I
said there's a lot of stuff in this
movie that reminds me of other movies so
you know um okay so it turns out that
after Mark gets all his organs ruptured
with the
DodgeBall um Julie who obviously this
was her fiance so she's inconsolable now
she starts having dreams about father
Damon she do know who the [__] this is
cuz she she never met him but he ends up
leading her like his ghost or whatever
like leads her to Margaret's house and
at this point we find out that Julie is
actually the person that's hosting the
Archangel Gabrielle but she didn't know
it until now right so her and Margaret
kind of get together they figure out
what's going on so they're going to you
know battle Lucifer together like when
the time comes you
know now for whatever reason a bunch of
the students I think it was are doing
like a whole play of like the last
supper and the crucifixion and all of
that I don't know if this was supposed
to be around Easter time or what or they
were just doing this for shits and
giggles or I don't know it just seemed
really weird but they're doing it like
on this big outdoor stage and it seems
like most of the town's people like come
out to watch it because I guess there's
not a lot going on in this town hey
let's go see that you know what I mean
so while that's going on in like a bar
nearby Andrew's dad comes in and he's
already pretty like pretty drunk you can
tell even though it's still daytime and
he's ranting about his son being the
devil and there's kind of a funny moment
where like the guy next to him is like
oh yeah you know my son he's the devil
too and blahy blah you know what I mean
but it's obviously not the same thing
but like nobody believes him he starts
getting like super Rowdy so the bouncer
like kicks him out and then he goes home
and shoots his wife in the head like and
kills her so that's nice cuz remember I
said like the iron fell on her head but
she lived you know what I mean she was
just kind of she was just handicapped
like cuz she was like brain damage she
couldn't like really move anymore so he
just goes home and shoots her so I'm
like oh that's nice I don't know what
happened to him after that I don't
remember um I don't think they show him
again now that I'm thinking about it now
at the same time that all of that is
going on there's also a school dance I
think and then at the school dance
though like Tony gets drunk and punches
a guy in the bathroom for like pissing
on his shoe because it was dark in there
I don't know it was a whole thing um and
then so Tony and his little band of
misant and pink lady knockoffs they
decide they're going to go have their
own party elsewhere because this one's
like really lame right now they go to
this dock or whatever and straight up
steal this dude's boat and they go out
to the Castle place that's out on the
island like from the beginning of the
movie where father Damon like killed
Lucifer from the
beginning now Andrew Lucifer is already
out there he's been hanging out there a
lot like he's kind of drawn out there
and he sees like various lights and
things like that that I guess other
people don't see or whatever um he's out
there sacrificing dogs and he's
wearing this is where remember what I
said earlier how I thought like I'm not
really sure what the intent behind this
was like maybe it was slightly
homophobic but maybe not intentionally
so Andrew is out there
wearing how can I describe this he's
kind he's naked but it's also like this
black robe but it's sheer you know what
I mean but it's I don't even it's not
even quite like a robe because it's just
kind of like a I don't know know I'm
sure there's a name for that garment but
I'm not really sure what it is it's just
kind of like a robish type situation but
it's like see-through and he has like
full makeup on and then you know like
lipstick eyeliner the whole thing and
then he has this like curly perm you
know what I mean like he has this Widows
Peak type situation going on which he
had before but it looks like they like
put big curlers in his hair so he had
like these kind of like fat curl it's
like very strange and it's just like
seemed like a weird
situation so like I said I'm not really
sure if the director intended to make it
super clear that Lucifer was gay and
that was like a bad thing I don't know
like I said maybe it was unintentional I
don't know um
so and the way that the actor is playing
him he's like camping it up like it was
intentional so I don't really know I
don't know I don't know how to feel
about it it was like super weird I'm
just like what the [__] is going on here
you know what I mean it's just very
strange um yeah so I was like
yeah uh and it gets even weirder because
Andrew like magically wakes up a whole
bunch of dead dudes that are buried on
the property I think it was mentioned
earlier that these were all the workers
that had died when the castle was being
built so I guess they were all just out
there like oh all these people like
disappeared you know what I mean but
they all just are dead out there so he
woke them all up like some of the guys
look kind of like normal but some of
them like look super zombified like the
makeup they're kind of covered with this
lumpy oatmeal and Gore and stuff like
that um and they kind of a lot of them
have like the white contact lenses like
youd saw like in the Evil Dead you know
what I mean so kind of similar to that
so there's another thing that reminded
me of like another movie although Evil
Dead I think came out the same year as
this you know what I mean
um thank you
Tom nice cans you're so classy Tom he's
always like watching me from the other
room when I do these streams and ab like
comment on the boobs Yeah well yeah I
just I did um my hair looks good because
I did my roots this morning that's why
so it looks all one color instead of
like having all the [__] you know
having all the roots okay so um so yeah
so all the zombies wake up or whatever
so Tony you know the the bully guy and
his gang they show up to the Castle
Island and then most of them get killed
like offc screen sadly by the zombies
There's not like a huge amount of Gore
in this
sadly now
Andrew confronts
Tony and
supernaturally gives him women's tits
did I make that up I did not um yes I
realize that sounds completely Bonkers
but in its
defense it does actually relate back to
something that Tony said to Andrew
earlier in the movie about like he was
trying to get Andrew to come and smoke
pot with them and he's like you don't
believe that rumor that smoking weed
makes you grow tits right and I was just
like
what I was like is that a real was there
ever really a rumor that smoking weed
would make a man grow tits I had never
heard that before ever I'm like it's I'm
like that's so [__] random and so I
guess him saying that and then the whole
thing with Tony like trying to kiss
Andrew in the shower so I guess he's
like oh I guess you're like a woman now
so I'm going to give you breasts and I
was just kind of like this is [__] this
is a weird [__] movie I'm like what
the [__] is even going on so yeah um so
Tony is so appalled at having
breasts that he looks right at Andrew
and he screams [__] you at Andrew and
then he proceeds to like stab himself in
the tits killing his own stupid self
with
which
okay good job I mean you really you
really showed Lucifer what's what there
didn't you hey give me women's tits I'll
show you and then he St himself to death
the tits and I was like I don't
understand what's going on in this movie
right now but yeah uh Tom said yeah weed
lowered something oh okay see but I just
never heard that I never heard that
before so it's like in this movie came
out in ' 81 I was like was this an ' 80s
thing that I just missed out on because
I was too young to like smoke weed in
1981 I don't know it was just like so
weird but like the fact that the fact
that Tony is just in there and unbuttons
his shirt and he has boobs and I was
just like this is a weird kind of movie
yeah so um so yeah so Tony stabs himself
and then Lucifer who's just cackling and
just over the toop fabulous right in his
like see-through robe or whatever now he
carries the last remaining teenager who
I think is named Brenda she wasn't like
a super big character or anything like
that she was just one of the Gang and he
puts her on an altar to sacrifice her
now while all of this is going on Julie
and Margaret the two uh stealth
archangels they've been kind of like
hustling their asses off to try to get
out to the island themselves so they can
defeat
Lucifer now I neglected to mention this
earlier because there's a lot going on
in this movie like at the same time you
know what I mean but remember I was
talking about the whole Jesus play that
was going on in the Town Square or
whatever okay well that didn't end up
too well what ended up happening was
that the guy playing Jesus he's like up
on the cross being crucified or whatever
like not really obviously he was just
tied to it cuz it's a play but he
started having like Stigmata for real
and then um so he starts like bleeding
and then I guess he dies from the from
the stuff cuz he has like the wound in
the side and everything like that um and
then he gets struck by lightning and
then everybody watching the play like
also spontaneously starts bleeding like
from their wrists and from their you
know forehead and everything and then so
then they just all scattered but then
they all started dropping dead too like
I guess like presumably from blood loss
or some of them also got struck by
lightning too it was just like a really
weird situation so Margaret keeps
talking about the second coming so I'm
not sure if that's what this is or if
that's what they're trying to imply cuz
some people just like wandering around
going oh my God what's going on you know
what I mean um you know I'm not
religious so I don't really know what
the what the deal was but I was like
well maybe that's what that is you know
I I don't know it's just weird so
juliean and
Margaret finally get to the castle
island with the with the big cross that
father Damon had um so and it's just
it's glowing like the whole time with
you know that um I'm not really sure I
know there's a word for it but I can't
remember what it is right now but you
know like in the 80s where they would do
that overlay of like the light and it
was kind of glittery you know you know
what I'm talking about if you've seen
light movies from the'80s okay so the
cross has that but so it's like every
time they move it it's just like woo
it's just like light everywhere you know
what I mean um now I will say that even
though it looks like Margaret and Julie
arrive in time to stop Lucifer from
stabbing Brenda like you know because
she's on the Altar and everything they
kind of let it happen anyway they're
like standing there like hey Lucifer and
he's just like yeah and they're just
like oh well we probably could have
stopped that but okay too late now you
know what I mean sorry Brenda I was just
like all right they were right there so
yeah so so then I'm thinking okay so now
there's been a human
sacrifice like does that mean Lucifer
wins cuz prior to this he'd been
sacrificing animals just like kind of at
the beginning so I was thinking oh
animal sacrifice animal sacrifice Human
Sacrifice B bomb like Lucifer wins I
don't I don't know like so but
apparently not though because Julie and
Margaret that they start like chasing
Lucifer through the castle and he ends
up by the tree like where the first
incarnation of Lucifer got killed by
father Damon like at the beginning of
the movie and then the archangels like
try to get him to recite um The Lord's
Prayer right and he kind of seems like
he wants to so I think the implication
like I said this wasn't super clear but
I thought the implication was that he
was trying to fight Lucifer like within
him cuz Lucifer was inside his body but
he didn't necessarily want him in there
so he was trying to like fight him off I
don't really know so he does like keep
trying to to say it but he keeps like
messing it up and then he gets kind of
like pissed off and then he snaps
Margaret's neck uh so yeah so she gets
killed and then Julie who is the last
remaining Archangel um she had she ends
up like being the last one to kill him
with the magical power of the special
effects cross like he kind of like
Lucifers out at the end like with the
contact lenses and everything like that
it's crazy looking now after that
there's like there's a shot of Margaret
and Julie and father Damon and they're
all like coalescing like into one thing
like I guess like the Three Angels as
one or something cuz I think this was
something that they were talking about
um earlier on in the movie but I wasn't
really sure like what the mythology
behind it was cuz I think they kind of
talked about it but it wasn't I don't
know it seemed like a little convoluted
I thought but you know what I mean so
they're all just kind of like woo we're
all one thing now we're going back to
heaven or whatever the hell I don't
really know so yeah um you know he went
full Jesus yeah hi doer said a very
weird movie it was a very weird movie I
mean it it was like it was very weird um
so yeah so I'm going to say like for an
early 80s flick it was okay um I think
it had like enough entertainment value
and weirdness to it that it kind of kept
me interested um even though it did kind
of have long stretches where it was kind
of boring and I'm like let's kind of get
on with this cuz I didn't like the high
school stuff was a lot more entertaining
than the religious like the angel people
you know what I mean cuz that was kind
of boring and very I don't know that was
kind of like a SLO to get through cuz
they're just always talking about we're
the Archangel and we have to go fight
the we're like yeah okay we get that so
you know what I mean it's that just kind
of went on too long I thought but yeah
so there was that whole situation um
some of the acting going to say was not
great um you know like I said the
mythology especially about the Angels
like the archangels was a little bit
convoluted I don't know if they
necessarily needed three of them you
know I don't you know what I mean it's
that kind of thing um and you know some
of the scenes kind of dragged on like
way longer than they need to but you
know if this kind of sounds interesting
to you at all because like I said it is
kind of bizarre you know um it so if
you're interested to see like a just a
very weird kind of
unsettlingly homoerotic maybe not
intentionally um mashup of the omen
maybe Grease
and maybe Carrie like just because of
the high school aspect and stuff like
that I mean then you might want to give
it a go I will say that my favorite
thing about it still was the soundtrack
um and really that almost kind of like
salvaged the whole movie for me it's
almost like worth it just like hearing
all those great songs in there but other
than that I don't know it it it was
strange and it entertained me but I
think there was I think it should have
concentrated more on the high school
stuff and it's funny because Frank loia
the writer director
he said later that um when they were
releasing the movie like the production
company or whatever they marketed it
more toward the high school angle you
know what I mean like they um the poster
which I think I used on the thumbnail is
like a yearbook page like with that's
burning and stuff like that so they
focused a lot more like on the high
school angle because he's like oh well
the marketing department were like oh
well we didn't want to go too lean too
hard into the religious angle CU they
thought that it would you know turn
people off which maybe they were right
about that but I will say that I thought
the high school stuff was a lot more
entertaining than the religious stuff
was like you can still do a movie with
Lucifer as a high school kid I mean
that's a good premise um but I don't
think they needed to spend as much time
with the archangels and maybe it would
have been better if all of the
archangels had been other high school
students cuz like as it was only one of
them was and then there were two more
then like one of them was already dead
and then one of them was is like an
older lady so I don't know so I kind of
feel like maybe they should have just
set the whole thing in the high school
you know I think that would have been
like a lot more entertain it could have
been like weird as like it what like it
was cuz it was pretty weird but I don't
know I think all the stuff with like the
older lady and the the real serious like
religious stuff I think that was felt
kind of out of place like especially
because the high school stuff was like
tonally a lot more like Carri you know
what I mean so I don't know uh so I
think that's kind of why I didn't I
liked it I just didn't love it like I
probably wouldn't ever watch it again
you know what I mean that's all I'm
saying but yeah like I said I can't
remember who it was that recommended it
but thank you for recommending it
because there's some there was some
pretty weird [__] in here that like I
just can't even explain it I'm just like
watching it going what the [__] am I
watching and it's funny because I saw on
I watched it on shudder and I always
read like after I watch it I always like
read the little reviews like underneath
that and I think that was the first
review somebody said what the [__] did I
just watch I'm like yeah that's about
how I felt about it too but yeah it's on
shutter um I'm sure it's on other
streaming services too if it sounds like
you know if you're into ' 80s hor and it
sounds like something that you'd be into
um it's pretty entertaining but there
are kind of long stretches of boredom in
there so just know that going in but you
know what I mean all right so I guess
I've been waffling on about this long
enough so I guess I'm going to wrap this
up um we're going to do a movie review
tomorrow evening which will either be uh
we did watch um the man who killed
Hitler and then the Bigfoot
so we might do that or uh I think zanada
sent us um the Cocaine Cowboys
documentary like the original one and I
think it's supposed to come today if it
doesn't come today then we won't be able
to um do that but if it does come today
then we might watch that and um talk
about that tomorrow but we'll see how it
goes and also I'm planning on
doing we'll see if I have time but I'm
planning on doing like another book
review and another movie review this
week Pro maybe to Tuesday maybe one on
Tuesday and one on Thursday um and I
wanted to do Christmas ones so I'm
actually reading a Christmas horror book
right now um that I hopefully will get a
review up and I want to do I might do I
might change my mind about this but I'm
going to do a Christmas horror movie
that came out last year um called
Christmas Bloody Christmas uh which is
also on shutter so I might watch that
and do a review of that sometime in the
week as well just because you know
Christmas is coming up and I feel like I
hadn't done like I did a wait further
instructions which which is kind of a
Christmas horror movie but I felt like I
needed to do some more Christmas horror
like leading up to the holiday so you
know what I mean yeah High Desert said
shutter added some Mario Baba movies
yeah I saw that today uh yeah I just
went on there today and I was just like
oh look at all the stuff they added they
have a [__] ton of um kind of lesser
known Galo movies on there too that they
added a little while before uh hi deser
said is it on shutter this movie is um
fear no evil yes this is on shutter and
also um Christmas Bloody Christmas is
all is on shutter yeah so that's
probably why I'm going to be end up
doing that one but yeah so I guess I'm
going to wrap it up so thanks everybody
for dropping by and watching me talk
about this weird ass movie today and uh
we'll see you guys again um tomorrow
night good night